[Music]
spider-man far from home is tearing its
way around the world after having just
released worldwide so in anticipation
for it I decided to go back and watch
the Marvel movies in chronological order
from beginning to end to rank them from
worst to best this is the sixth time
that I've done this and I love
revisiting the film's with the added
context of the sequels and Easter eggs
throughout this video I'll be going
through each film one by one to let you
know how it compares to the rest and
what I think of it this list covers all
23 films including far from home so it
should give you an overall idea of how
good or bad it is without the way I'm
your host definition I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
I hope you enjoy it now let's dive into
my list of the 23 MCU movies ranked from
worst to best Thor Thor comes last on
our list for a number of reasons firstly
the film feels slightly by-the-numbers
with a betrayal of Thor that is
difficult to connect with the dialogue
feels overly Shakespearean at which if
you know of Kenneth Branagh who directed
the film is expected it just doesn't
feel fitting for the MCU the piece is
cliched and due to its pacing it feels
slightly disjointed and its third act is
just very underdeveloped if one were to
judge Thor purely off this film alone
and know for a fact that many would not
hold the character as the fan favorite
that he now is overall it feels
underwhelming and that's why it holds
last place The Incredible Hulk when
going through a watch of the MCU The
Incredible Hulk definitely feels like
the most unnecessary out of the films
the origin story is skipped over mainly
due to the Hulk film that covered it a
couple of years prior and Bar General
Ross nothing from this movie really gets
touched upon in the later films the
action CGI AMPA elements all feel
slightly dated by today's standards and
this movie hasn't held up in the way
that say Iron Man did overall it's
totally fine however due to the quality
of the other films on the list it's hard
to rank it any
Captain Marvel Captain Marvel sees the
first female LED film in the Marvel
Universe and showcases the origin story
for Carol Danvers aka Captain Marvel
unfortunately for me the film feels a
bit flat and lacks the wit and ingenuity
of the other Marvel movies whilst the
Skrulls twist was surprising and samuel
l.jackson steals the show brie Larson
just doesn't capture my interest due to
her lack of charisma and aloofness and
that's why it ranks so low on our list
Iron Man 2 Iron Man 2 had some pretty
big shoes or should I say suits to fill
and not to give anything away but its
predecessor is one of my favorite comic
book films ever made and this one falls
flat in almost every department when
compared to it the arc for Tony isn't as
strong the villains are both
underdeveloped and don't really put up
much of a challenge and whilst there is
a nice metaphor for the gun control
debate with the government trying to
strip Tony of his right to bear arms it
feels slightly meandering even the
normally outstanding scholar Johansson
feels pedestrian here and overall it's
just a bit underwhelming Thor the dark
world Thor the dark world is a real
guilty pleasure of mine and whilst it's
hated by many I absolutely love the film
it's got fast paced actions some great
twists and it also makes Thor far more
likable than he was in the first film
whilst the villain is very very
underdeveloped
this is Loki's moment to shine and he
secures himself as a fan favorite based
of this movie alone Captain America the
First Avenger
well it's Captain America the First
Avenger is often overlooked I actually
really enjoy the film due to its heart
message and period setting the movie
beautifully portrays what it takes to be
a hero and excellently interweaves the
propaganda aspect of the character that
was prevalent throughout the Second
World War add to that the ever so catchy
star-spangled man and you have a hit on
your hands that's my second favorite
origin story from phase 1 Iron Man 3
Iron Man 3 is another guilty pleasure of
mine and luckily or unluckily depending
on how you look at it I had the big
twist from this film spoiled for me
months before I actually saw the film so
I didn't find it that jarring I can see
the bad in it but due to the
performances of Downey and Don Cheadle
have a great time whilst watching it the
airforce one rescue scene is incredible
and one of the best action pieces in the
Marvel movie franchise and a completely
fanboy out over the final battle with
all of the versions of the suits this
film really secures Iron Man is the
coolest character for me and whilst the
script may not be the best there is
definitely a lot of fun to be had here
oh yeah and it's a Christmas movie
ant-man and the wasp ant-man in the wasp
may not live up to the first film in my
eyes but it's still a lot of fun and
upon its release it felt like the
perfect palate cleanser for the events
of infinity war this really takes the
character in a new direction and the
house arrest motif that constantly sees
Scott battling between helping his
friends or seeing his daughter is an
inspired choice the film uses San
Francisco to full effect and also has
one of the coolest looking villain
costumes ever put to film with the
design of the ghost this doesn't really
possess the stakes of the other movies
but it's still an enjoyable ride that
showcases the dexterity of the MCU
Doctor Strange Doctor Strange brings
magic to the MCU with a spellbinding
tale about the titular characters
journey of enlightenment well it's the
initial hour of the film is slightly
derivative of Batman Begins it takes a
complete 180 and benches into untried
territory that's laden with outstanding
effects and a unique final showdown
overall Doctor Strange is a fun ride but
I find it slightly to formulate to
scratch the upper echelon of the MCU and
that's why it gets a position here
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 depending
on what day it is guardians 2 jumps back
and forth with the first film it's my
favorite out of the tube once again
though during this walkthrough I
actually preferred the first film over
it that's not to say it's bad though and
this is an incredible second outing for
the characters nebula becomes a
massively likable antihero and this
father-and-son story really delivers on
a lot of levels I mean what's not to
love about an adventure with baby crew
exactly guardians of the galaxy
guardians of the galaxy is by far one of
the funniest films in the franchise
he took the cast of characters from the
Zed list and was a huge risk for Marvel
that paid off massively not only does it
set up the space side of the Saw
it also builds upon several elements of
the MCU such as an appearance by Thanos
Ronan the accuser the collector and the
Infinity stones guardians is a movie
with a lot of heart and it's one of my
favorites Avengers age of Ultron
Avengers age of Ultron gets a pretty bad
rap in my opinion the film is one of the
most developed villains out of the saga
and this movie beautifully puts cracks
in the relationship of the team that
would come to fruition in civil war the
Hulkbuster fight is outstanding and one
of the best action scenes in the series
and whilst it doesn't match up to the
first Avengers film it isn't really
trying to and that's what a lot of
people get confused I really enjoy it
even to this day and that's why it ranks
high at the most ant-man ant-man took an
absurd hero and show that Marvel had the
ability to make even the most obscure
name a mainstream hit the film is full
of fun from beginning to end and it
tells the story of a father on the wrong
side of the law
trying to do good by his daughter and
did that the comedic delivery of Paul
Rudd and outstanding special effects and
you have a small hero that makes a big
impact on the list black panther black
panther was groundbreaking in many ways
as not only did it completely reinvent
the africa s sake it also did it in a
way that made it seem mystical and
futuristic this was the first time that
we really saw a Marvel hero lose and the
arc of kill manga is as fascinating as
the movies protagonist it's no wonder
that this film got nominated for Best
Picture when it does so many things bang
on spider-man homecoming spider-man
homecoming not only works as a fantastic
coming-of-age story but it's also the
most accurate take on the webhead to
ever be released this is a fun-filled
ride from start to finish that features
knockout performances by Michael Keaton
as the vulture and Tom Holland is be a
Parker add to that the mentoring that
Tony saw provides and you really get a
fleshed out film that makes you friendly
neighborhood spider-man slop perfectly
into the AMC Captain America the Winter
Soldier Captain America the Winter
Soldier was when the MCU got serious
this political espionage thriller is far
advanced beyond its years and it really
feels like a grounded angry take on
characters that are in it the movie
expertly tackles privacy terrorism and
the government in an adult manner that's
still very fun to watch this movie too
has a heart and that's why it still
stands as one of the best films in the
franchise
spider-man far from home spider-man far
from home feels like one of the most
important entries in the run with the
titular hero pretty much becoming the
new face of the universe as he slowly
learns what it's like to become a hero
as always power and responsibilities of
big aesthetics here and the movie
solidifies Tom Holland as film's best
spider-man add to that some neat little
twists and turns awesome action scenes
and an adventure that takes the
character around the world and you have
a unique film that manages to better its
predecessor far from home is another
solid entry and definitely deserves its
spot in the top 10 thor ragnarok thor
ragnarok totally reinvents the titular
character and puts him in a hilarious
film that's far removed from the
original movie at this point Thor had
become a fan favorite and this film
cements him as one of the best Avengers
all of the supporting cast really bring
their a-game and the movie introduces
call to the world who is probably the
funniest MCU character ever created add
to that the inspiration from Planet Hulk
the destruction of Asgard and an amazing
performance by Jeff Goldblum and you
have one of the best MCU movies ever
made Iron Man Iron Man kicked off the
MCU in spectacular fashion this film had
to be a success for Marvel in order to
kick-start their grand vision and there
was a lot riding from its shoulders
however due to perfect casting
outstanding CGI expert pacing and a
relatable hero that turned a scoundrel
into a role model the movie succeeded in
several ways it's one of my favorite
origin stories of all time and ranks up
there with Batman Begins and it's just
brilliant from start to finish the piece
works as an outstanding 9/11 and Iraq
war metaphor with an arms dealer having
to handle the repercussions of arming
the Middle East terrorists to the point
that they were able to fight back even
today it stands as an amazing piece of
cinema and that's why easily secures a
spot
the top five the Avengers the Avengers
changed the landscape of film and Herald
it in a new generation of shared
universes that all failed to live up to
this first instance in the industry from
beginning to end the movie and capsule
eights the comics and feels like an
outstanding Batian brought to life on
the big screen overnight this turn its
heroes from being c-listers to the most
profitable comic book characters on
earth whether it's the incredibly witty
dialogue provided by Joss Whedon or the
phenomenal action in the city of New
York everything feels like it's
innovating while setting the bar high
enough that many would fail to live up
to it every hero is fully fleshed out
and developed and this is the perfect
team of film from beginning to end that
on any given day depending on what mood
you're in could be considered the best
in the franchise Captain America Civil
War vs. movies are 10 a penny and
they're often pretty lackluster Civil
War however is a shining example of how
to do it right in the same year that saw
the release of Batman V Superman Civil
War managed to perfectly capture what a
rivalry of this scale should be like
whilst adding a heart to it that its
competitor sorely missed this movie is
epic from start to finish and contains
many devastating moments such as the
death of Peggy Carter the reveal at the
Winter Soldier murder the Starks and the
collapse of the Avengers add to that the
introduction of spider-man black panther
and the seminal airport sequence and you
have one of the best superhero movies of
all time but nominal from start to
finish civil war deserves its spot in
the top three films Avengers infinity
war in my hair before seeing infinity
war I thought there was no way that this
could live up to the hype Thanos had
been teased for 10 years as had the
Infinity stones and with almost every
character from the franchise in the film
it just seemed impossible for the Russo
brothers to pull it off however against
all odds they managed to infinity war is
a complete masterpiece that possesses
perfect pacing outstanding action scenes
but also an unforgettable ending that
will arguably stand as one of the
greatest twists ever put to film for a
long time infinity war not only nails
everything that attempts to do but it
also surpasses all expectation Hank
it's an outstanding movie from beginning
to end that showcases why the MCU is the
most popular film franchise of all time
this is a complete masterpiece and
deserves its position here on the list
Avengers endgame Avengers and game
rightfully deserves its spot at number
one on this list as it's an absolutely
incredible film from start to finish the
movie has some outstanding action from
beginning to end but it also packs
emotional moments that will have you
laughing with joy in some parts and
crying in others this is the perfect
send-off for every character in the
entire MCU and honestly if this was the
final film in the franchise it would
feel like one of the best send offs of
all time this movie is not only the best
on the list but it's also the best comic
book movie ever made and that's why it
secures its spot at number one and
that's our list obviously I love to
yours and we're you ranked spider-man
far from home comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed it then please
like it and make sure you stay locked to
the channel for our ending explain
breakdown on the movie later in the day
we've also just covered the new footage
of Avengers and game so if you want to
know what happens in the re-release then
make sure you head over to that video
which would be linked at the end this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you